everybody you're not going to want to
miss this episode of the into the
impossible podcast featuring a scientist
i've known for well over half my life
incredibly impressed with him when he
was an undergraduate at brown university
where i was a graduate student he is a
theorist uh by training but he works on
some of the most cutting edge aspects of
physics ranging from information theory
uh quantum mechanics the multiverse one
of the foremost proponents of
visualizations of the multiverse and
inflation but also an old-time
cosmologist in a young person's uh
persona in that he really doesn't just
dismiss things because of you know
received wisdom in his book cosmological
cohens which is one of the most
delightful books i've ever read uh and
kind of the spirit of a of a stephen
hawking or carlo rivelli you will find
yourself
be twixed and and bemused by this
wonderful book which is really a
travelogue uh that takes place in the
1600s and kind of teleports the reader
uh through time and space to encounter
the most magnificent
and uh mesmerizing concepts in the in
the world of physics in cosmology
ranging from the arrow of time to
cosmological inflation
to the big bang the steady state
as well
and ultimately the meaning of paradoxes
called koans
in this case it's professor anthony
aguirre university professor at the
university of california santa cruz way
up north one of the northern uc schools
in this wonderful university that i am a
part of and i'm proud to be a part of
this university because of professors
like anthony so i do want to uh uh alert
you to this uh to this amazing podcast
you're gonna love the interview
and we covered so much he's a close
close friend and colleague of carlo
rivelli himself and max tegmark and many
other great scientists sean carroll
that we've had on the podcast and uh and
i
can't believe that someone so
skilled in sort of the hardcore
quantitative arts of theoretical physics
can write such a magnificent um book
that's kind of part zen in the art of
motorcycle maintenance combined with a
uh with a book on modern cosmology so
you're not gonna miss it please do me
the favor of subscribing to the uh to
this channel on youtube or if you're
listening on itunes or stitcher or
spotify or any of those places follow it
subscribe to it if you can't leave a
review that really helps me we're up to
about 200 reviews so far i can't tell
you how much that means to me that's all
i'm asking for and so for now sit back
enjoy the phenomenal the effervescent
anthony aguirre a man i've known since
he was a young kid and now he's a
university professor highest
honor we can give to a faculty member at
the university of california and for
good reason
so enjoy this episode with anthony geary
and stay tuned for more wonderful guests
coming up on this podcast
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
and today it is a great pleasure to talk
to
a friend of mine a colleague a fellow
professor in the same university that
being the university of california
and that is anthony aguirre who is a
professor of physics at uc santa cruz
home of the banana slugs i always forget
that's correct that's good okay so
banana slugs that's why you never come
down to
to uh to you see irvine because there
might be an anteater that mistakes a
banana slug for an ant and eat anyway i
don't know why i would bring it because
it's also very dry you know we like our
moisture
that's right anthony i've known you
since you were an undergrad at brown
university when i was a graduate student
uh so so much older so long ago
and yet they won't even come close to
talking about the subjects of your book
which take place in the 1700s
and that book is is really a work of art
anthony you know we haven't talked uh
very much lately recently with the
pandemic and so forth i stopped by your
neck of the woods about a year and a
half ago right before
kovid sort of kicked in and i wanted to
to stop in and see you but we didn't uh
we didn't get to connect but but
nevertheless here we are and in that
time i hadn't read your book at that
time even though it was published by the
same publisher published losing the
nobel prize which is uh norton
and and endorsed by some of the you know
most luminous luminaries in the world
including my new friend carlo rivelli uh
who is teaming up with me
and another italian physicist to make
the first audio book of galileo
galilei's
a dialogue on the two world systems
which features uh plays a role in
cosmological cohens
and uh that is it really a book as
carlos said a gem of a book i found it
magical i found it really delightful and
you know it's like i read these books
and and they're written and i'm sure if
you ever get a chance
you can skip over most of my book
because you know a lot of the physics in
it it's the personal story that's
different this book you really can't
skip over so much and very dangerous to
do yeah it is and and it has such a uh
delightfully playful approach to the
biggest questions in the universe the
smallest things in the universe and uh
and everything in between uh so first
welcome to the anthony impossible
podcast i've wanted to have you for a
long time so glad you can make it
thank you it's great to be here
so um
this book was seemingly came out of
nowhere and yet there's nothing really
else like it uh it's sort of when you
pick it up and you see cohen you think i
immediately thought oh great uh
anthony's gone woo
he's gone
he's gone to the woo lee master side of
things uh no offense if what whatever
his name is gary or whatever his name is
out there uh but i was a little afraid
you know we see coins you see the you
know physics of god and the god equation
which is now coming from our friend
michio kaku will be on the show shortly
um
what what inspired you to write this
book anthony
i think it was it was really thinking
about what
what i find
inspirational as a physicist i i think
there's a
a sense that what physicists do is like
you know sit down and do dry technical
stuff and they try to make predictions
and they run gigantic experiments to
test
physics theories and all of that is true
you know all those are part of the job
description um
but for most of the people who are
really excited about physics like like
you and i and and many of our colleagues
that's not we why we got into physics to
to like write grant proposals and sit on
committees and and like look for funding
for massive you know
experimental programs we got into it
because i like that actually i like
being on commitments you like being
committees and fundraising i get lost
gotcha um
but i i think most of us got into it
because we
we see this world around us and
want to understand how it works and as
we discover some of what science has
discovered about how it works we we
realize how
crazy and mysterious the truth of how
the universe works really is
that it's not at all
the way we think it is you know in our
everyday
life
uh you know we've got objects and they
kind of move around and there's physics
that describes that but as we get deeper
and deeper into it we understand you
know how mathematical it is how
paradoxical it is how counter-intuitive
things are uh
when compared to sort of our everyday
understanding of things and and the
magic i think of physics is
seeing that there's this
kind of secret world behind kind of
behind the scenes there's this whole
other way of looking at what the world
is doing which is
uh
different and also true and
and mysterious uh and you can come to
understand more of it but the mystery
remains and in fact i think
uh part of
part of what inspired this book was the
feeling that
the deeper you go the more you
understand about how the universe works
the more mysterious and the more subtle
and interesting the questions get
and so my hope for this book
was to to really try to give a reader a
bit of that experience that um there are
there are strange things about the
universe and there are big questions
physics like what is the dark matter you
know this is a big interesting question
um
but there are a whole bunch of other
big interesting questions that are very
subtle and very deep about the nature of
reality that you don't read about so
much um
and so that's one one goal and the other
goal i think was to
to give a little bit more of the uh
i write in the book
a wonderful description by
albert einstein
who said one of the one of the most
beautiful
uh experiences that a person can have on
paraphrasing here is of the mysterious
you know to see that uh behind as i was
saying behind
the sort of facade of the world there's
this deeper reality that we can that we
can only touch upon
and i wanted to try if i could to give
the reader a little bit of that
experience
and
and as i recount in the book
there's some parallels to this and the
process that takes place in zen buddhism
where the idea is not to sort of impart
knowledge on you
but to give you an experience to
confront you with a question
and confront you sort of so forcefully
with that question that you have no
choice but to sort of be
all about that question and in awe of
sort of what the different answers could
be to that question or how or what that
question means what it means for you
so there was an inspiration in this
method of zen
of kind of
sort of
confronting the student over and over
again with more and deeper versions of
fundamental questions and that's kind of
what i wanted to do in the book to take
the reader and kind of and bring them to
this place of
here's here's what we know about reality
but there's this question here you go
have at it think about that
um
and to bring them to that place where
that's so wonderful as a physicist to
say
i don't get it i don't understand how
can reality be that way and yet it's got
to be like this or it's got to be like
this but they're both super weird uh
that that feeling of strangeness of the
way that the world really works i wanted
to to help the reader come to that
yeah i find that's dichotomy that we
have as physicists on the one hand you
know people as you say look at
physicists at towards the end of the
book you talk about how you know in
principle it should be i think
rutherford said something like that you
know everything is either physics or
stamp collecting meaning that the laws
of chemistry can come from the laws of
physics the laws of biology can come
from chemistry which comes from physics
et cetera et cetera so there's this kind
of in so we have this you know swagger
associated with ourselves that we're you
know kind of the top apex predators of
the scientific world
and yet you know this book and uh really
points out this that undermines that
that
that pyramidal structure because you
really reveal not that we're ignoramuses
but just that you know as
as as wheeler john archibald wheeler
said frequently and you quote him
throughout the book um i'd love to know
if you ever met him i never did but uh
but uh but but wheeler said something to
the effect of you know as our as the
island of knowledge grows so does the
boundary of our ignorance you know the
coastline of our ignorance grows too
how do you handle that you know when you
you know you have young kids i have kids
you know they think of us as just like
we're wikipedia basically you put an ask
them a question i will come and answer
and yeah we can handle most of the ones
that are tough for lay people why is
this guy blue you know what uh what you
know what um you know what caused the
the uh the the galaxies to move away
from us whatever uh but we can't answer
you know what happened before on a
tuesday before the big bang yet uh we
can't say what are electrons made of yet
or you know what is the true fundamental
theory do you think that's just a
byproduct you know in other words of our
success and that we've explained so much
with so little uh just the laws of
mathematics and some observations we've
only been doing this since about the
time of galileo in a quantitative form
what do you attribute that to and are
you uncomfortable like not knowing
because it seems like a con
if i'm not mistaken is sort of a paradox
that makes you uncomfortable or should
yeah i would say
you know my reaction to that is is sort
of one of
delight and opportunity in that i think
once you really understand something
really well
it's not
that interesting to keep thinking about
right you know certainly as a as a
physicist
um we we learn newtonian mechanics for
example you know in in high school or
college
and
there are you can go sort of deeper and
deeper into newtonian mechanics but but
nobody wants to just spend 30 years
doing inclined plane problems like you
can get really good at them but
okay where's the challenge uh it just
doesn't get it's not interesting anymore
so i think
what is amazing about
the way the universe has turned out to
be is that it is both
uh comprehensible that we can make
tremendous progress in understanding
how it works to the extent that we can
you know make predictions that that show
11 decimal places of accuracy uh we can
launch satellites along the right
trajectory to to basically then just
coast their way to another planet you
know
that we can do all these things with
enormous precision and yet it also
holds enough mystery
um that there are so many still open
unanswered questions and even some of
the most basic simple ones like you said
what is an electron
we know everything about how electrons
act in order you know in the sense of
predicting everyday phenomena that
involve electrons uh we can do it so
well you know we can that we
can devise devices and and with
whatever characteristics we want
whatever behavior we want we can build
computers with gigantic amounts of
computation built into them but the
question of what is an electron exactly
in a way that
is really
sensible and really
feels
comfortable in a sense and you feel like
yes you told me now i really know what
an electron is that doesn't exist at the
moment
and that's an amazing thing to be able
to
understand the world so well in certain
ways but still have that mystery there
but i'm so happy that that's the case i
i would find it so disappointing
if i felt like the whole world was just
fully understood
we understood how everything worked and
there was no more
mystery there i would find that terribly
disappointing other people might find
that comforting and
and pleasing but not me though
so that's my own personal
uh
preferences i guess that i that i would
want that mystery to remain there
yeah and it's sort of uh echoes a
conversation that i've uh that i had
with the late great freeman dyson and it
actually did involve religion you know i
i you know i'm forbidden to convert by
nature of what my religion is
he was a matter of the jason society
allegedly uh it's top secret but they
meet here in san diego california and la
jolla and so he'd come to visit in the
winters for some reason he didn't like
being in princeton in the middle of
january so he'd come down here and uh
and spend some time we got to know each
other really well he's actually like 90
years older exactly than one of my kids
and they got along really well and we we
talk a lot and sometimes we talk about
religion because he was famous for kind
of being
an agnostic in some sense you know
devout agnostic as i call myself is is
not too far from what i perceived him to
be
um and i said well what is it about
religion you know that is interesting to
you why don't you as most you know
scientists are pretty fairly strongly
held in terms of secular and he said
well you know god is a mystery and you
know and science is a mystery there may
be puzzles along the way
and the distinction he made is you know
puzzles can be solved um the mysteries
perhaps can't be you know you were
always a better student than i was
anthony so you you could solve some
homework problems or whatever that i
could never do and uh but but but there
might be mysteries that you can't solve
and i can't nobody can solve and that's
kind of the essence of these koans so uh
taco sir what what inspired you i mean
are you a buddhist i mean have you been
like have i known you for 30 years and
secretly you're a buddhist
i i've i've dabbled in the sense that i
i've certainly read
uh buddhism i've sit i've sat buddhist
meditation retreats so i
um
i don't like being
any iss too much i still you know i do
consider myself a scientist but uh you
know that
that's a bit of
that's a bit necessary but i you know i
try not to
adhere myself too strongly to any
particular set of beliefs uh other than
the ones that i i've
you know
feel a really good
uh
have
had sort of a professional interest in
in some sense but
so yeah certainly i've i've read
you know buddhist philosophy and and
done some practice
um
but i think this
this is the you know the purpose of this
book is not so much about um
you know trying to merge physics and
buddhism or something i think there are
there are some
there are some nice parallels in in
certain places but but it's more
um
here is this
parallel in
in method really uh
and and a little bit in experience like
the the sort of
mystery and awe and kind of don't know
like
god i just don't know
uh that is part of most some of the most
fun
interesting science i think has a
parallel in
the the questions that buddhism
confronts people with of who are you
what is this about you know what are you
as a as a person in this world what is
the meaning of all of this those those
existential questions and it's not just
buddhism of course that confronts you
with these things i think um
but i think the the there's a parallel
in that
uh the part of the zen practice
is to
confront you a bit more forcefully like
not let's idly speculate about
who are you but like who are you right
now who are you answer the question and
you're like i don't know who i am what
am i i'm just this thing um the sort of
bafflement uh
is it makes you very uneasy in a sense
but i think is also sort of a gateway to
like
a deeper investigation of yourself and
in the same way i think these i hope
that these questions that are in
cosmological poems are are kind of a
gateway to deeper investigation of
reality uh of the
the physical universe that we live in
yeah um
it wouldn't be the first time though
that uh
members of the buddhist persuasion were
practicing physics uh in your part of
northern california our mutual friend
david kaiser pointed out and how the
hippies say physics many of them were
not located too far from where you are
in our lovely city to the north i do
miss it and i hope we can get together
in person one of these days either you
come here i've been there a couple times
uh including around the bicep two affair
which we just celebrated it's march 2021
recording this now we just celebrated
the seventh anniversary of the
announcement of bicep twos yeah um you
know ill-fated announcement but uh you
were kind enough to invite me to give a
colloquium there yeah i had a wonderful
time and i met some some wonderful
colleagues of yours and in fact you know
i'm remembering you did you do quote
freeman dyson actually in one of the
chapters of the book in correspondence
with
dick friedman or richard feynman right
who i'm sure we'll get to uh but uh in
this concept of you know what sounds
crazy
maybe maybe so but it may be true
and i think yeah there are these
interesting kind of commands and so
you've answered that
because i think it kind of um aligns
itself nicely with what we do in physics
it is it is sort of you know these these
inscrutable things that the more you
think about it the less you understand
perhaps um but uh but but maybe as
wheeler said you're just pushing this
that that's a byproduct of of this of
this game and i think you know maybe
just combining the bicep two
experience with this book and with what
you talk about you know i i often
thought during bicep too that there you
know obviously there was a huge
competition to win you know one of these
which you know they uh one of my guests
john mather filled with chocolate
i can't say
but um
but you know the competition to do that
i think you know to win a nobel prize
and as i said i have michio kaku coming
on and and he's not afraid to to be a
little on the woo side of things but um
in his new book the god equation he
keeps tweeting out that you know you can
be the next einstein and win a nobel
prize and be a physics god if you can
discover this equation which is one inch
long and it contains all the mysteries
of the universe and you know first of
all what kind of font you know could you
write you know even the
the laws of string but i want to ask you
one of the questions i've been really
ruminating on a lot lately is you know
do we need a theory of everything and
this is kind of my brian's co-on
actually i have a couple that i'm going
to run by you for
you know the second edition of
cosmological cohen's which is just such
a lovely book
i really feel like it's a book that
you could give to somebody i've been
dealing with some extremely well-known
individuals who are uh very wealthy very
successful and um they they're like i
want to learn quantum mechanics and i'm
like all right well do you let's start
with trigonometry
out of like you know if you put in the
effort you learn trigonometry which is a
prereq you can learn it but uh one of my
cons is you know is sort of do we need a
theory of everything like who says there
is a theory of everything uh because you
know when i when i talked with sir roger
penrose on the show
a couple months back i said this to his
face or at least to the screen
i said roger you know you and hawking
prove these singularity theorems and and
uh black hole theorems etc but the uh
the circular logic which lends itself to
the keating koan
is to is to say well the only two areas
that i ever hear we need quantum gravity
for are for singularities in the black
hole or in the beginning of time if
there was a beginning of time and uh and
yet both of those are inscrutable
completely and we can't go through an
event horizon we can never get some data
from inside of a black hole we can never
go back and observe the physical
conditions that time equals zero if
indeed
time had a zero point which you discuss
in the book um so i wanna ask you you
know what what is it what is it about is
it just this need not only to to wrestle
with koans but but to come up with them
ourselves because i don't see that
there's some letter from god or from you
know the buddha or from whoever or from
fineman i mean just take feynman as a
god he said if it doesn't i don't care
how beautiful your theory is anthony and
you have some beautiful theories uh but
i don't care how beautiful it is if it
doesn't agree with the experiment it's
wrong now i said that to john preskill
who's the feynman professor of physics
at caltech and he said
i said what about string theory we can't
even see if it's wrong
it might not even be wrong and he said
well you just have to try harder so what
do you say well you know or is it a
fool's errand is it a buddhist quest
what is this quest for the theory of
everything
yeah well there are a lot of pieces of
that i think one is uh
why do we think of
a theory of
sort of fundamental particle
interactions
um
including quantum mechanics and
including gravity and including all the
other
uh
fundamental forces why do we think of
that as a theory of everything it's sort
of clearly not a theory of everything in
the sense that
there are many many questions for which
that theory will be absolutely useless
uh in predicting anything
so it is a so there's
the the very question includes a sort of
world view in which there's a
a sense of
their
levels of description of reality uh
there's the everyday level with with
objects moving around and things and
substances and stuff there's a sort of
chemistry
level of reality there's a
particles and fields level there might
be a string
or whatever level
so everybody sort of agrees that that is
the case that there are these different
ways of looking at reality uh that are
useful for different purposes string
theory will be totally useless for
deciding you know what the
what the climate is going to look like
next week you know you don't need string
theory you don't want strength here you
can't use it you want uh hydrodynamics
and a climate model in a big simulation
right
so it's utterly obvious that everybody
agrees that
these are these different levels of
description of reality are good for
different things but there's a there's
also a world view that says
but the the the lower down ones the more
fundamental ones are more real and more
true and more right in some way
and so
as we get more fundamental theories
we are getting better and truer and more
right theories until we get the most
fundamental one and that's the most true
and most right and that's the theory of
everything
and i think you know i never quite
bought into that world view there i
always felt like something was a little
wrong with that um but as a
card-carrying theoretical you know
high-energy physicist at some level i
had to adhere to that that creed for a
long time but i think
you know as time has gone on i've just
less and less been able to swallow that
idea um that that there's something more
true or more right about the more
particle or field based descriptions of
reality
and and more
sort of accepting of the point of view
that that reality is what it is
uh there are many different sets of
tools that we can use
to investigate and understand it that
reveal different truths and different
things that are useful and not useful
and different ways of understanding
reality using them
um and they're consistent with each
other to a large degree that
i
i won't find in my everyday physics of
the world that you know energy
conservation is totally violated and
that things can just pop in and out of
existence and and there are reasons for
that that i can
sort of trace to
what i call more fundamental
levels of reality
but i can also trace things the other
way you know that uh
given that the everyday world is the way
it is chemistry couldn't be that
different you know particle physics
couldn't be that different these things
are very connected and what you call
more fundamental as i've you know as i
argue in one of these cohan's is really
rather unclear when you start to to
really analyze what we mean by
fundamental
so so i'm
i at some level take a little bit of
issue with the question of the theory of
everything uh being a theory of
fundamental particles or fields or
strings or whatever i i think
there may be some
some theory that we come to
that we have trouble finding anything
uh to improve upon in the sense that we
have trouble finding
uh
physical phenomena at that level of
description
that aren't accounted for by that theory
but that will not be a theory of
everything
i don't believe
um
now in terms of the technical details of
like why do we
why are we discontent with
the theories that we have of quantum
mechanics and gravity
as you said there certainly are places
where we know
we can't just do with one or the other
uh we
that there are
sort of physical paradoxes that occur
that if you just naively say something
is gravitating like it is in general
relativity and it's
quantum mechanicating like like it does
in quantum mechanics
that you you can't write down a
consistent set of equations that make
sense in both
ways um
and
you know so that need is the need is
there intellectually um
i i think i would agree that at the
moment it's not there
experimentally in the sense that we
don't have
experiments for which
they're
you say oh i can't account for this
experiment using the the
known physics that we have
other than uh questions about cosmology
and like
uh the nature of the dark matter the
nature of the dark energy
where
you know
relics like baryons that we're made of
came from uh so they're these
cosmological questions but as you know
it's it's very difficult to find things
terrestrially
that
uh that confronts us with some piece of
experimental evidence that doesn't fit
into
the physical theories that we have
um so yeah i think in that sense we we
want those theories we we need them if
we want to
feel that they're that at the sort of
particle and field very tiny
microconstituent level of reality that
things are consistent and
comprehensible
but i don't think that if we found a
theory that did that
we could say okay we're done we
understand what reality is and how it
works and we don't you know i'll get my
t-shirt and we'll be done we can pack up
our bags and go home because you know
science is is complete
um
so yeah that that way i see would be my
feeling
when i uh think about the book um you
know can't avoid
the impression that the setting of the
book and i always hated anthony when you
were asked to go on a podcast and they
the host says you know can you tell us
everything about this book
and uh maybe um you know so just save
you know 20 bucks so that they don't
have to buy
an actual copy of it please you know
that's i want to deliver value to my
audience we never ask for that my
audience gets the value from the guest
and they read the book hopefully they
will buy many copies of it it certainly
is
one of the most delightful books i've
read in a long time it's really no
parallel to it carlo revelli you know
kind of comes to mind but even he
had to submit that this is a gem of a
book that he did not write himself
so i want to congratulate you on that
and uh and i want to just ask you a
question because
i can as the host of the into the
impossible podcast do this um i want to
ask why did you said it when you did i
don't think it will spoil anything to
tell the readers that the book is a
journey and it's an experience but it
kind of jumps between times but it's
always taking place in the 1600s it
interleaves the middle east the far east
and uh and actually europe and it takes
place in some parts you know before
galileo was galileo in a sense and and
as you may know galileo is is one of my
heroes
i write about him a lot i have even a oh
yeah of him um so yeah why did it more
of a fan than i
uh
i don't have a puppet i have one of the
anthony aguirre one over here no that's
that one uh so yeah why does it take
place in that time and why does it take
place where it takes place
yeah so originally um so this is just a
sort of
uh
a history of the the ideas in the book
at some level
originally i thought of when i thought
about writing physics co-ons
i just started having ideas for ones
that would take place in all kinds of
different locations and settings and
everything so i just started writing
them down
i then tried to
kind of organize them into
different time periods so i could have
some sort of narrative
and i ended up with some that were
taking place in
uh
in japan in sort of the 12th century
that's when when the great zen teacher
dogen was teaching some that were taking
place in italy with galileo and then
some that were taking place now
but then it started to feel like they're
three different time periods everything
is in not in order
hard physics ideas nobody's ever gonna
possibly you know even make it through
this book it's so confusing
that may still be true
but i i mean i tried to to boil it down
a little bit uh by picking one time
period and
and turning it into a single journey so
the the book does recount a single
journey that you know starts in italy
ends up in japan takes uh
30 years or so of of historical time and
although the the koans don't happen in
order there is kind of there is an order
to them um which would be even fun to to
read sometime the koans in the book in
their in their
historical order yeah that would be
rather different
um
so i think it's an amazing time because
it is the birth of science really in the
western world well the birth of science
period at some level with galileo i i
don't think that's any real exaggeration
it was astonishing i'll fanboy a little
bit on galileo now is astonishing
you know you read his dialogues and
and i basically transplanted one of them
directly into cosmological co-ons you
know and attributed of course
because they read so much like modern
physics reasoning i mean you can just
read them right now they totally make
sense you're totally thinking wow he's
really oh my god and that's true
if you go back and read plato aristotle
for example it's in a very different
sense
you're confused reading it it somehow
doesn't connect you have to really pour
over it to try to understand what
they're saying yeah
like it's like right there it was like
it was written last year and he even
comes up with things that are you know
philosophical and and psychological i i
had this quote i did a um a video
called the deconstructing the dialogue
and and i actually read the whole book
which prompted me to realize you know as
i did with your book i listened to it
because i can set it on 2x speed and and
get through it in only six hours for
your book but galileo i was like oh man
this book's 550 pages longer than
anthony's book us is going to be
ridiculous and i know people on my
channel are getting sick of me always
talking about this project but i'm very
excited about it uh because there is no
audio book of the dialogues you may know
and reading it it's one of the most um
it's one of the most delightful books i
think in in human history there's a
there's a passage in this conversation
between these three interlocutors where
um segredo who's kind of the educated
lay person i'm going to play segreto
and this work uh with carlo rivelli
being salviati as you couldn't guess
which role he's gonna play uh and then
my good friend lucio picharillo is gonna
be simplicio the simpleton but the the
part that i get to read is one of them
is is the following uh which goes by the
name of the dunning-kruger effect in
psychology and it goes like this galileo
writes as or segreto says uh this vain
presumption of understanding everything
can have no other basis than never
understanding anything for anyone who
had experienced just once the perfect
understanding of one single thing and
had truly tasted how knowledge is
accomplished would recognize that of the
infinity of other truths
he understands nothing
and i think it's so cool because he's
like basically saying like the more you
know the more you realize how little you
know but you also can have this false
impression of your own abilities so
yeah he is
he's just an amazing writer he talks
about the value of money and and and
what people trade he was kind of a stoic
and he had this kind of zen quality to
him too he was of course not without as
many foibles but um but you're right
going through this so how did you choose
1608 why not i always think it would be
me in my book i talk about him in 1610
after the after cedarius nuncius was
published but why did you choose that
particular period
i i should be first of all particularly
clear that
uh as a work of history uh
cosmological koans is um
you know
what's the polite word uh nonsense
it's you know based on it includes
historical figures um and i've tried to
use real historical figures and
uh and a little bit of a sense of what
was going on in these different places
at this time but it's also got a genie
um you know and a vast conspiracy across
the multiverse
so it's not to be taken as a
historically true document um so i
i you know i wanted to to roughly in
terms of galileo uh
pick a time where
you know that would include the the
coming across the telescope there's one
column that talks about you know
thinking about telescopes and
microscopes um
and
you know i tried to make the the
experiments at the uh with falling
objects roughly contemporaneous with
when they were supposed to be
but you know i'm not a historian and i'm
not gonna i'm not going to represent
that that anyone should
uh
read it you know it as an accurate
historical document it's it's really
the physics i tried very hard to make
exactly right but but the history
yeah uh
i will
if historians read it i can only
apologize
so but i found it yeah just just
completely delightful uh so the but the
zen master that you mentioned anthony
that was a real figure i'm just not
familiar with that aspect of zen well
dogen didn't appear in this book because
i i put it all in the 17th century so um
so he was earlier there's some quotes by
him uh the 17th century uh coincides
with the kind of
uh
the the period in japan the ido period
with with uh
the shoguns and and samurai and all that
sort of thing so it was interesting
there
um
there was a book on my
my father's bookshelf the unfettered
mind so the unfettered mind
is a book by
by this sort of swordsman and and zen
master
that was sitting on my bookshelf
as a kid you know and and i was
fortunate enough to grow up in a house
that had you know i had a father who
wasn't a physicist or or a scientist um
but he had a deep abiding kind of lay
interest in it so so his bookshelf was
chock full of paul davies and michio
kaku and all kinds of entrancing books
about how weird the world is uh but it
also included some eastern books and and
one that i remembered is the unfettered
mind so i was delighted to come across
that this is exactly the time period
where
the author of that book
lived so this is it's always fascinating
when you see just like with galileo
something
you know you pick it off your bookshelf
and find that there was this living
breathing person
back there that wrote these words and
that are coming to you it's kind of a
magic thing
that you can reach across history like
that and really make contact with
someone um but he was at this time uh
there were and and so i tried i sort of
picked interesting historical figures
and tried to weave them into the
narrative
um
of that
that sort of archetypal journey from
west to east also i think there's that
sense of
the
uh you know i don't want to be demeaning
to the the west here obviously this is
just it's also a a journey sort of from
youth to to maturity as it goes on
because the the protagonist sort of
leaves italy
as a youth and arrives in in
japan as a middle-aged person after
having traveled the whole world so
hopefully they've accumulated a little
bit of wisdom
so there's a little bit of that that
sense as well yeah
so i want to talk a little bit now as we
move away from the book about
your your research in cosmology and um
and actually you know the last kind of
stepping stone from the book will be you
know there's kind of a beautiful passage
you talk about
uh you talk about inflation you talk
about the steady state theory
and many other kinds of um
kind of explorations of modern cosmology
in the 20th century and what we know now
and there's a passage where you talk
about inflation
and the you know eternal kind of chaotic
inflation of linday and others and you
say that in a certain sense uh we find
in doing so
that you get the big bang you know kind
of stitched into the steady state
uh in that you kind of make it so can
you expound upon that a little bit more
and then i'd love to talk to you about
you may not recognize this room but but
uh this is the office once held by the
late great jeffrey burbidge
and jeff uh inhabited this office and
was not a big fan of the big bang as you
know right uh and actually you did uh
some of the most recent work that was i
quoted in my book on uh ways you could
salvage the big bang uh sorry you could
salvage the steady state model of
jeffrey burbidge but can you first tell
us what do you mean by you know stitch
the big bang into the steady state or
you know maybe even vice versa it could
work just as well yeah well yeah so the
the
what was beautiful about the steady
state theory uh as a you know so that
just to backtrack a little bit there
were two
kind of rival theories that were in the
cosmological world in the 50s and 60s
and a little bit the 70s the the big
bang model where the universe started in
some hot dense early state a finite
amount of time ago and has expanded
since then
and the so-called steady state and
the steady state had similarly had an
expansion
but it had an additional property that
the universe was and always will be more
or less the same at all times so the
steady state
although the universe evolves locally
globally it's kind of always the same
and what was really appealing and i
thought beautiful about this theory is
that
the big bang theory is based on
what einstein called the cosmological
principle which is that
there isn't a special place in the
universe that that everywhere in the
universe is kind of the same as
everywhere else there's a center there
isn't a oh look this is the top of the
universe or anything like that
everywhere is statistically speaking
more or less the same and if you go on a
large scale it looks more or less the
same and the steady state just extended
this time they said there's not just
no special place or direction in the
universe but there's no special time in
the universe every time is more or less
the same so it's a kind of more
symmetric more
organized in a sense more principled
version of the universe a slight defect
of this theory was that it was just
wrong
observationally it does not appear to be
a case so there are things that are
evolving
that we can see and you know this was
true in the 70s and 80s but it's super
true now there's just simply no way you
can make a steady state like idea work
for the observed universe
and so we we kind of vacillated big bang
steady state big bang steady state and
big bang resoundingly
triumphed in the sense that the
observable universe appears to follow
the big bang theory
but this really interesting thing
happened i think which is that
the theory of inflation which was
devised
essentially is it as an explanation for
the early conditions of the big bang
theory why did these universe have these
particular properties at this early time
that it is hot and more or less uniform
and dense and expanding with just the
right level of fluctuations in it why
does it have those properties the
inflation was devised as a way to
explain those properties based on some
fairly simple set of physics
um
and and processes and it does so quite
beautifully
but
and so it was thought of as as sort of
this little
fix that you would stick into the big
bang like there was there was a messy
kind of universe there was a big bangish
stick in inflation it fixes everything
up and the universe is nice and very big
bang
uh uniform isotropic
expanding doing all the right things
sometimes when you change just a little
bit of something you find that it has
much bigger implications than you
thought and what has happened with
inflation is that
uh it was discovered fairly early on and
developed ever since then that
inflation very much has a life of its
own the very properties that allow it to
fix the big bang
um
also
give it these this these semi-magical
properties of being able to bring into
being a tremendous amount of space time
and
matter to fill it
so the
the particular properties of
the substance that has to drive
inflation the inflaton field is that it
essentially
creates more space it creates this
anti-gravity force that blows the
universe apart
but as it blows apart it doesn't get any
less dense so you create more
space but also just the same amount of
energy filling that space
and so it's it's this
uh
feels like cheating kind of process
there are ways in which it's not
cheating that you can you can sort of
talk about but it feels like cheating it
creates this gigantic space
more or less out of this tiny little bit
and
but this process is very hard to stop so
once it gets started
it's very hard to stop the universe from
inflating and blowing up and creating
more and more space and time
and so what people discovered early on
was that
if if the physics is
right for it and it often is what you'll
find is that it doesn't stop it only
stops locally in some little place and
that looks like a big bang universe like
we see but elsewhere inflation just goes
on and on forever never ends this is
called eternal inflation
and
once you
admit
that possibility
or once you sort of postulate a theory
that has that property to it
then the large scale picture of the
universe
becomes much more like the steady state
because this inflationary process that
goes on forever
you can show that what that actually
looks like is that the universe is more
or less the same at all places and more
or less the same at all times on very
large scales so it's a revival of the
steady state the internal inflation is a
steady state picture
in which
here and there little big bangs kind of
go off where inflation stops and a big
bang cosmology begins and so i just find
it fascinating that we
this this vacillation between you know
newton thought that the universe was was
infinite and
you know infinitely old infinite age
infinite in size
then we replaced it with a big bang and
then there was a steady state and now we
have this crazy combination of the two
where locally it looks like a big bang
but globally it could be this very big
steady state picture
um
so so it's an amazing thing where again
you think you've got it all worked out
oh the big bang it's right universe is
13.8 billion years old we understand it
all but then you realize well okay that
might be just this tiny tiny little
speck
in a vastly bigger and more complicated
background
ah that's uh very delightful to hear it
from
the man himself who has i believe the
honor of uh
the actual description being attributed
to you in the encyclopedia britannica
is that not correct
that you have described the multiverse
yes multiverse that sounds
more impressive than it is i think it's
true that encyclopedia britannica
when they had run through everyone else
landed on me to write the entry for
multiverse
i used to get these things like um
you have been selected to appear and
who's who among you know american
individuals or something and if you pay
the 59 99 99 you can appear in the next
edition so i was the sucker that said
yes to this thing write an article about
the multiverse collection hypothetical
collection so that's what i want to get
into of potentially diverse observable
universes each of which would comprise
everything that is experimentally
accessible by a connected community of
observers
and you go on a little bit i want to ask
you when we hear about that and we hear
about the string landscape
i am going to be having a conversation
quasi debate with a intelligent designer
who is an intelligent intelligent
designer his name is stephen meyer he
wrote a book called
darwin's doubt and another one called
the signature in the cell and he's got a
new book called return of the god
hypothesis in which he does battle with
lawrence krauss and others over some of
the uh
necessary but perhaps insufficient
descriptions of fine tuning that there
is in uh modern cosmology and modern uh
bio molecular biology
et cetera et cetera
but but he also goes through the string
landscape and and talks a lot about that
and necessary conditions for string
theory uh to produce a multiverse like
entity i want to ask you something that
i've never gotten a great answer too so
we often hear and you describe this in
the book too that it might be possible
in such a
multiverse to get any value you like of
any of the physical constants which in
some sense might alleviate the so-called
anthropic principle
paradox which is a type of cohan i
suppose
but in other cases it might make it even
more complex because you know the number
of the sheer number of universes uh that
could exist according to you know string
theory 10 to the 500 10 to the 1000 and
you go through this and you go through
some of um
some of um
uh some of the objections that penrose
himself had with entropy when you
describe entropy in the book but i want
to ask you a question i often hear that
uh we'll have different laws of physics
in each one of the string
landscape models or maybe even in each
of the multiverses um so i have two
questions one is um why is it that just
changing the vacuum you know the vev the
vacuum expectation value
in a string theory collision manifold
how does that change the laws of physics
in other words would there be five you
know fundamental forces would there be a
hundred whether it be one um that's
question number one uh and you could
choose to answer it or not and then
question number two is why stop there in
other words why only the laws of physics
why not the laws of mathematics why
would anything be the same in any of
these universes that are completely
different
entities from the one that we inhabit so
first yeah why why does changing the
vacuum value of the energy of a
configuration called equilibrium why
does that lead to different laws of
physics
yeah so
so what what's left out of that sentence
is
a few words so so what they really mean
are
it will lead to a different set of low
energy effective laws of particle
physics and and this is this is very
important because they
the assumption is that
uh the two sort of pillars of physics
quantum mechanics and general relativity
um
as they might be combined into string
theory in this picture they're unchanged
so there's still this uh in this
sort of
paradigm or kind of way of thinking
uh there's still this kind of platonic
idea that the there's some fundamental
laws of physics that are mathematical
and form they exist
sort of transcending physical reality in
some sense they're the same everywhere
and at all times and everything
and those are
you know
string theory
which includes quantum quantum mechanics
string theory which is sort of based on
quantum mechanics and includes general
relativity but then also includes these
other
uh sort of
local
uh lesser forces like electromagnetism
um
so that that's an important distinction
that some of the laws of physics are
held to be the same everywhere and at
all times and in this sort of
transcendent sense
and other ones are thought of as kind of
local
conditions much like the
you know
the laws of hydrodynamics
uh sort of
work
well there would be there's some
particular
you know rules of hydrodynamics that
function in this room that are
particular to the setting of this room
and elsewhere you know the the laws
might be similar but there'd be
different conditions there might be more
different gases involved there might be
you know some different initial can some
different boundary conditions of a
window open or whatever
low they're more local things
um so the
excuse me
so the
the way that story works
is that
um as you said there's there's this
string theory
uh and there these
this is a bit of a long story but to
make it very short
uh it was shown
actually not that long after einstein's
general relativity
that if you had extra spatial dimensions
the behavior of
fields in those extra spatial dimensions
uh when you confine yourself to less
dimensions so if you had a five
dimensional space
or space time rather four dimensions of
the space and one of time if you confine
yourself to three dimensions for one
reason or the other like the extra
dimension is really small or you can't
get to it or for some reason you can't
access that other dimension so you just
get to experience physics in the three
spatial dimensions that we have
um
that there will still be a sort of
manifestation of that extra dimension as
fields that are in our space that have
properties and dynamics so what they
showed in particular was that if you had
five-dimensional
uh space-time and general relativity
you could get from that four-dimensional
general relativity
three-spatial one-time dimension plus
electromagnetism it just kind of came
for free
where the the
the field that the electromagnetic field
essentially
is another name for
this extra hidden dimension in a sense
this was by kaluza and klein
and the idea of string theory is that
it's this on steroids that
all of the stuff that we call
electromagnetism and the strong and weak
force and the symmetries that they enjoy
are all really properties of these
hidden extra dimensions
and so if you change the properties of
those hidden dimensions
which can physically happen from in
different places in different times then
you change the properties of the
the effective physics that you see in
our
pedestrian small three plus one
dimensional universe and so we say oh
look there's
two versions of electromagnetism or
there's no electromagnetism or
you know there's there's an extra strong
force that behaves differently or
whatever um
they
they emerge from those extra dimensions
in just the same way that
electromagnetism does in the collude
decline theory
and
uh and there's no reason that those
can't vary from place to place while at
the same time relativity again and
quantum mechanics are the same
everywhere in this picture
so then that would explain why the laws
of mathematics wouldn't change or laws
of logic or could you envision
multiverses where even
you know two plus two equals five
i yeah i think that's that's a
a fairly different question i think you
can
um the
it's certainly the case that the the
sort of multi-verses that
there are many different versions of the
multiverse right there's the the one
that i just described the string theory
inflationary one there's the quantum
mechanics one if for believers in the
many worlds version of quantum mechanics
and in that one all the laws of physics
are essentially the same and it's just
different branches of this wave function
then people have entertained
sort of
more
uh even diverse multiverses in which
the
the question that that i believe stephen
hawking asked
there's a set of particular set of laws
of physics why does
reality breathe life into this set of
laws of physics and make a physical
world that is governed by them but not
these other ones
that's an interesting question and one
answer to that question is that
you know that's not what happened that
all of the sets of equations have life
breathed into them
and they all exist in the same way that
ours does so that's a point of view that
you know max tag mark and some others
have taken
that
every
set of physical laws that exist with
every presumably every set of boundary
conditions that there could be
are
correspond to a real physical universe
in just the same way that you know the
ones that we seem to to experience do
and i think that's an interesting
and sort of self-consistent answer to
the question of why one particular set
of laws of physics
are the laws of physics are real you
know get to get to govern a universe why
are they so lucky you know and all these
other sets of laws of physics don't get
to govern anything
so i think that you know that's an
interesting idea that's very hard
um
you know it's not one that i personally
uh believe but again you know
belief is a is a
um
it's not
it's one of the things that i
you know if someone says that's crazy i
will defend how it's not crazy if
someone says that's true i will defend
how that's totally crazy so it's one of
you know one of those things that i
think the right response to it is
yeah that's crazy but it could be true i
don't know
and there are a lot there are a lot of
those things
it's funny because i have a guest coming
out in a couple of weeks
who has caused me to reevaluate my views
of stephen hawking he wrote a book
called the hawking hawking it's a
critical biography of stephen hawking
and actually i i had finished reading a
brief history of time i started reading
in 1989 i finished reading it in 2021
and it wasn't it wasn't only because
it's it was some parts of it are a
little bit um dense but uh actually that
was the obstacle in the beginning and
then by the time i was done with it and
i was a you know full professor at uc
san diego i fully understood it and it
was parts trivial but there are parts
within it where he talks about uh work
that he did with our other colleague in
the middle of the state uh jim hartle
about the hocking hurdle no boundary
proposal and uh and i started to realize
he
he was an excellent writer actually the
the book has almost no no um
complaints from me about it because i
really uh i really love uh his writing
and his character and and the things
that he says but you know and upon
reading it as a mature person
uh yeah i i found it very uh very
suspicious the things that he did
especially even in the revised third
edition i think is the one i read uh
from 2016. so this is after bicep two
this is after uh you know many things
and he really made the case in that book
there were two
uh you know real purposes for a god in a
universe and one was to create the uh
you know originate the universe what
role for a creator if time didn't have a
beginning
and that was the notion of the no
boundary proposal which is the basis of
a brief history of time
which i only realized as a you know a
fully tenured professor
but
and then the other purpose for god would
be to instantiate the laws of nature and
he claims that is provided in the grand
design by m theory and i started
thinking about this like neither one of
those has you know any observational
support at least right now uh and
it's very troubling to think that you
know he really in one hand and the no
boundary proposals you know he basically
says well if you make time imaginary do
what we physicists call make a wick
rotation you can transform away all the
time like properties of of time and make
it a spatial dimension that will be
like a dimension on a sphere it has it
has no boundary it may be compactified
but it has no boundary and he even says
in it this is just a mathematical trick
and later it's like now you see we don't
need the beginning of time so what is
your creator and if we can get the laws
of nature we'll know the mind of god i
mean that was one of the first times he
said that yeah and i just found it a
little disingenuous uh that that he
would do such a thing when he knew for
sure that that you know it really wasn't
so solidified even hawking hard i don't
know how many people uh really put faith
in that in that no boundary proposal
other than an interesting way to solve
uh the wheeler dewitt equation perhaps
yeah but i want to i want to get into
because you are you gave an incredibly
popular talk at the seti institute about
bubble universes and
has your has your um
uh thought process evolved you know
since your earlier days when you made
really fundamental contributions to not
only our understanding but kind of
popularizing these bubble universes that
go on from without end i really think of
you when i think about that um have you
evolved in in any way i mean does bicep
affected you as you know uh other
branches of physical or are you as
sanguine as ever so to speak
well i think um
if you're asking about how have i
evolved in terms of of like how probable
i think it is that that inflation is
true or that eternal inflation is true
or something like that i would say
fairly similar to how i've always felt
that inflation seems like a
a good and relatively unrivaled
explanation for how
the big bang has the properties that it
does
and internal inflation seems to me like
a
if not inevitable quite natural
uh
thing to happen with inflation
and so i think both of those are to me
just as likely as they ever were it
certainly would have been nice to see
evidence of you know colliding bubble
universes in the microwave background
and and prove that that was happening or
at least get evidence for it um but even
when i was thinking about those
questions i figured that that was very
low probability that we would be so
lucky to see those so i think it
it's uh
so it's been frustrating in the sense
that some things that could have
happened that would have things made
things a lot more interesting and
exciting
haven't you know we haven't discovered
gravitational waves from inflation we
haven't discovered supersymmetry or
anything else of interest
in colliders we haven't discovered
colliding bubble universes or other
defects we haven't discovered anything
wrong you know with the the standard
model of cosmology and the microwave
background radiation that we can really
point to
which is super frustrating yeah um but
all of those things were
at least a little bit hopeful you know
some of them were more hopeful than
others uh you know
it was it was there was certainly a
higher probability we were going to see
gravitational waves than colliding
bubble universes um
but
there are plenty of versions as you know
of inflation where you don't see
gravitational waves
right and
so
so we've we've been unlucky
i would say relative to
to how you know we could have been
luckier
but there hasn't been anything in in the
sort of progression of the
the experiments that have led led me to
say
well we've got something terribly wrong
or like we're misguided in this whole
picture just that frustratingly it's a
bit harder and going to take longer than
we had hoped to pin some of these things
down
i would say though that my
uh
my view my excitement about
figuring certain things out has shifted
a little bit
so so when i
when i was first studying physics you
know in college i
uh if i'd been able to skip the
thermodynamics course i would have
enjoyed that or statistical mechanics it
seemed like the most boring subject like
yeah
there are lots of particles instead of a
few
so what um
and it just seemed like a mishmash of
different ideas and it kind of was
useful for some things i could admit
that but it didn't seem really that
exciting intellectually
and that's something i've really changed
so i've spent the last five years or so
really thinking about statistical
mechanics and its foundations and these
questions
and this goes a little bit farther back
about the arrow of time
and cosmological boundary conditions all
of which are wrapped up in this big
interesting and information theory all
of which are connected with each other
and have become much much more
fascinating to me and so
i think my interests have changed and
what i find personally
like uh compelling as questions to
investigate has changed but i don't
think my beliefs about uh
things like inflation or the multiverse
have changed that much
now in terms of
in terms of hawking
you know i i think i've always been very
frustrated with this idea that
um
you know creating the universe from
nothing
uh in the way that they talk about it
with the heart of hawking or valencian
with this tunneling wave function or any
of the other versions of kind of
creating the universe from nothing
i've always felt and i think they admit
this if you impress them on it that it's
totally cheating right
the nothing is a very particular
meaning of nothing uh but it includes
the laws of physics and you know
hamilton
like all the mathematics it's all there
um it's a particular nothing which is
like a a universe of zero psi you know
you sort of look at the universe in the
zero size limit and you call that
nothing but it's really not at all
nothing right so i i think it's it's
important to
the question of kind of why there is
something rather than nothing
is just you know
those studies address it a little bit in
the cosmological context but they really
leave the meat of that question very
much
untouched i would say
yeah it is sort of unsatisfying but then
again you know koans are not meant to
necessarily
the delicious repasts
so in the final you know a few minutes
that we have uh you have another like 10
minutes anthony or yeah you have a
pretty hard out but uh
i can't resist this is so delightful for
me um i want to ask you a simple
question uh what causes time no i'm just
kidding that is uh
that is a koan in itself uh i want to
bring us back to your some of your
papers that you did in the late 90s um
actually they were just solo papers that
you wrote uh and some of them appear in
my book and they involve uh kind of what
it would take to dust dust their
favorite subject that's right yes the
villain of my book the gin of my book is
sort of dusted uh
but uh when i think about those those
papers you were kind of doing something
radical which is to you know perhaps try
to reconcile the
the the standard lore is that oh after
after penn state and wilson the big bang
uh won and quasi steady state was over
and of course
nothing could be further from the truth
and in fact you know the uh the
inhabitant of my office the former
inhabitant jeff burbidge went to his
grave believing uh that the big bang was
false and total rubbish worse than that
or better than that i spoke to uh giant
narlikar
on the podcast uh two or three months
ago
along with his wife who's an eminent
mathematician and we had a wonderful
time and he still publishes books you
know fundamental problems in cosmology
uh
and uh you know it's sort of i think it
comes down to
an uncomfortability a discomfort rather
with with singularities with beginnings
of time
uh and you know it's it's not at all
clear that the that the big bang
solution was really
as dispositive as most people think and
i pointed out in my book
the the word big words big bang don't
appear
in the companion paper to pensions and
wilson it was they only discussed that
was by dickie
bob dickey and and peebles and role and
wilkinson
and i'm going to have on i have on my
advisor who was one of your former
teachers peter timby is uh he was a
guest on the podcast that's in an
episode that's coming out soon but
anyway we talked about dickie and what
he really felt about the big bang and
that paper and again it mentions the
cyclic universe it doesn't mention
uh the big bang at all and it's not like
they didn't know about it uh so you know
when people say oh you know these guys
are fools hoyle and burbidge and
narlikar i don't you know i'm much more
sympathetic to them and and i kind of
see these echoes going on you know right
now with with uh my friend paul
steinhardt neil turock and others you
know maintaining kind of versions of
cyclic or amer bouncing cosmologies and
they're often ridiculed or you know as
outsiders and don't they know how how
successful inflation is
uh but i think you point out a lot of
these things the fine tuning problems
the entropy problems um
what would you say i asked sean carroll
you know over lunch once when i was
interviewing him a while a long time ago
he said what are the odds of that god
exist he said less than a half a percent
i said okay what are the odds that uh
the multiverse exists and he said 50 50.
so
you know you just said like you're
disappointed or it is disappointing we
haven't collided with another universe i
mean the odds of that are pretty pretty
low and and you know i want you to be
happy and not not depressed if this
doesn't happen in the future so you know
we think about this how much of it is
wrapped up in our need to want to
believe this particular type of story
you know kind of sociology which you do
get into in the book like how much of
physics is really sociology
um
well i'm not sure there's two separate
questions i think there one is um
you know why
there's a question of why
you know a small minority of
physicists continue to believe something
when it seems so difficult to believe at
this point
and i think there's
there's a fascinating
recurring theme where
um
i would say there's a there's a sort of
mainstream that believes a version of
physics or of cosmology a little bit
more strongly than they ought to given
the evidence
and then there's a another set of people
who say you're believing that a little
more strongly than you ought to given
the evidence what about this possibility
okay and then there's a there's a
vicious fight where where everybody
circles the wagons and and identifies
themselves with this belief which is
always a tricky thing to do
but the nice thing about science is that
uh as you progress one of those things
actually does turn out to be
right and true and sort of evidence
keeps accumulating for it and that
community of people who are doubting it
shrinks and shrinks but i i think it's
great that they don't entirely go away
um because it's it's us it's always
useful to have people who are sort of
playing the gadfly and pointing out that
the evidence for things is not quite so
secure as you think it is um
and
so i think that happened with the big
bang in the steady state and and what i
studied in in the late 90s as a grad
student the cold big bang model so when
i came across that you know i i figured
this is not
likely to be true right it's probably
true that all these people with a hot
big bang model are right but they're
kind of a little bit over confident
given the
like what what the evidence actually is
um let me see
how hard is it to make this whole big
bang model
work like what really would it take is
it so crazy what does the evidence look
like um and and i think putting
that was a great exercise for me to
understand both how hard it is to you
know develop a whole cosmology and have
it all fit together
but also how
strong the evidence was in some places
and how
not so strong it was in other places
so once you get off the bandwagon and
look at a theory from the outside
you you i think
discover yeah those pieces of it really
are very secure and well these are a
little bit more
it's iffy so i think it's very useful to
have people around who will play that
role and will take that outside
perspective and point out where the
weaknesses actually are
but i also think that you know as a
practicing physicist there's a point
where things just get boring so
so the cold big bang model got boring
for me you know after spending a while
on it because i just
it just wasn't fun anymore to try to
like
massage things into making sense when
they didn't quite fit with the data the
same thing i happened i think happened
with modified gravity there was a
a nice idea that maybe
you know in 80s that maybe what we call
dark matter is just a change in gravity
at very low accelerations or large
distances or something not a crazy idea
at all
when einstein's you know the the first
manifestation of general relativity
showed up as this procession of the
perihelion of mercury and people started
to invent different
you know clouds and asteroid belts and
stuff that would account for that they
caught you know dark matter but it was a
modification of gravity not a crazy idea
that that what we call dark matter is a
modification of gravity um
and it was it was an interesting idea in
the 80s and a little bit in the 90s and
it just got steadily less and less
interesting as more and more data from
all sorts of directions
just was perfectly beautifully
consistent with dark matter and not with
modified gravity so yes you can still
concoct
very complicated multi-component arcane
versions of gravity that could sort of
explain dark matter in some phenomena
but it's just not fun anymore right and
and i think
there's you know it's not so much
there's this there's this saying that
you know you have to wait for the old
generation to die off you know physics
progresses one funeral at a time
exactly i don't think it's quite like
that i think it's you know people get
bored with with thinking about things
that don't seem to be true
um and then there's a few holdouts you
know and it might take a funeral for
them but
uh
but i think
in all
it's a fairly healthy thing and i i
think honestly something similar is
happening in string theory i think
people are are streaming out of the
field at some level because
it may be true but it's just it's gotten
a little boring to keep coming up with
these beautiful theories and and
mathematics and working things out but
not having the feedback process that
gives you more clues as to what's going
on and so
the you know the strength your community
is branching off into lots of fun
interesting directions in terms of
thinking about the
you know black holes and information
theory and
condensed matter physics and all these
different things
um but the idea of just we're let's
figure out a theory that gives us the
electron mass from
fundamental considerations
you know
people have tried it and and it's not
that it's exactly failed it's that it
kind of
isn't that fun anymore to do
um so that so that i i think
i think it's not the case i think it's
the case that um
i i can't remember exactly how you posed
your question you know how much physics
is sociology i think
there there certainly is a lot of
sociology in the practice of physics and
you know creation of these communities
and bickering with each other and
things that are fashionable for a while
and more fashionable than they ought to
be
but it's also really
gratifying i think that
in the sweep of time the physics
community like other scientific
communities do seem to converge on
things that they agree more and more on
and seem to be more and more true they
they really do explain better they
really do work better you come up with
new phenomena and they still fit that
new theory not the old one
so the whole process i think is a really
beautiful thing that we've devised you
know going back to galileo
he couldn't have known
probably
how amazing a thing it was that he
invented this consensus truth-finding
practice
that that has led us
over these 400 years to the place that
we are it really does work
and it's an amazing thing and there are
lots of criticisms you can make of
science and lots of ways that it goes
wrong but i think we have to keep in
mind what a what an extraordinary
enterprise it is
yeah and of course you know galileo was
not without his faults he he believed
until uh well his dying day that uh
certain things about the universe uh
were
uh were completely different than the
way that we know them are to be now i
mean i don't know if you know what the
original title of this book was
anthony this is kind of a
test to see if you've subscribed to the
podcast yet i hope you will so this is
the uh the dialogue of course so the
original title just to save you uh the
the trouble was on the flux and reflux
of tides in the earth's rivers oceans
and ferns i don't know if you have any
ferns up there but but we don't have any
ferns over here but the point being that
he thought that the most dispositive
piece of evidence for the copernican
universe was the sloshing of water you
know that was caused by the combined
motion of revolution and rotation of
course we know that's completely wrong
well he also believed that the you know
comets were in the earth's atmosphere
but but certainly
that notion of confirmation bias now
look he was right the earth you know
does go around the sun that was
completely wrong information for anyway
i hear some buzzing i gotta go i know
you gotta go do you have like two more
minutes or should we wrap it up
uh i'll i'll give you two more and then
i'll i'll feel very guilty to the
prospective grad students who are who
are probably waiting for another maybe
that's my ploy to get them to come here
okay i wanna ask you um actually i'll
just ask you um
uh two two questions uh one is uh what
would you put in your ethical will an
ethical will is a wisdom will it's a
type of a piece of wisdom that you wanna
bequeath to your ideological errors not
necessarily monetary to your biological
errors what would you like to give most
um
let's see
yeah i i that's a that's a
difficult question i would say that um
that the i would probably want to impart
upon the younger set of them perhaps
that
um
that the questions really are the fun
part not the answers
awesome um
that's beautiful
uh the last question i ask all my guests
is kind of a version of feynman's
cataclysm question
except in this case since i'm the direct
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination i used the
monolith in 2001 a space odyssey
some
time capsule that lasts for a billion
years and so feynman was asked once you
know what would you put that contact
encapsulates all of scientific knowledge
if civilization were to be destroyed
that contains the most information and
the fewest words kind of a co-own of his
own and he said it was the atomic
hypothesis what would you put in what
what what discovery have you made in
your really eminent career i'm i'm so
you know i can't be proud of you but i'm
so impressed by you uh you're one of
you're kind of like this old old guard
of physics that's somehow fallen into
this uh my generation but i want to ask
you what would you put that encapsulates
the wonder of knowledge of science that
you've discovered by yourself or the
combined talent of all the scientists in
history that have led to this point
um
boy you have
hard questions um
speaking as a koan ask come on you
i would
um
i think i would say
um and this this is
this is not so much a
a summary of the way physics is now but
i think more of an injunction of the
the
the way it is in certain ways and the
way it ought to be i think
physics is to a surprising degree
constituted to make the world safe for
observers and and about observers and
that that sounds
totally
contradictory and against what you would
think about physics um
but i think
to think about
uh
the universe is both objective
and
constituted so that it makes sense and
has a consistent story to every observer
in it
uh when you manage to reconcile those
you have something of interest
well well that has officially blown my
mind my brain and uh makes me want to
get you one of these dolls now this is a
carl sagan doll carl sagan how where do
you get these things do you make them
no i have a team of
graduate students where no it's a place
called the unemployed philosophers guild
you can get them yourself but you
deserve one but you echoed something
earlier we said you know it's amazing to
read something and carl sagan said books
are proof that humans can work magic
because over the centuries a long dead
writer can be speaking to you i like to
say a podcast is proof that humans can
work magic because we can see you we can
hear from you and we can learn from you
and anthony i want to wish you all the
best
up the road in northern part of
california we love what you do we hope
to come back we didn't get to talk about
fqxi we didn't get to talk about future
of life all that fun stuff go go uh
attract some graduate students to become
banana slugs uh we love you and uh wish
you a wonderful rest of your rest of
your quarter etc
thanks very much it was just a
tremendous pleasure to be here and
thanks so much for doing the service
that you're doing and making this show
to to bring all of this fun to lots of
people it's my pleasure bye anthony v
well any sufficiently advanced
technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
you